we knew Instagram was an obvious place  for Apple to be many of the photos  posted on Instagram are taken with Apple  products so it's a natural fit a perfect  place for us to showcase our ideas our  products our voice but instead Apple CEO  Tim Cook has demanded that the feed  consists solely of photoshopped pictures  of his head on body builders bodies and  not good Photoshop like really the best  graphic designers in the world  but Mr Cook was like no no no let me do  it I can make these it's an  embarrassment  we asked Tim as this just for the lodge  will these photos be replaced at some  point Cook said no no this will be my  legacy Steve Jobs had the iPhone let me  have this  let me show my ripped torso to the world  I said Tim that's not your torso and he  said quiet  that is my torso even sufferable  European twit they've just and Miss  Steve Jobs Miss Steve Jobs so bad  why did he leave  [Applause]  you